moi je prends deux trois douches par
jour je me lave les mains j'ai le gel
hydroalcoolique dans le sac à main est
ce que c'est bien est-ce qu'on a raison
d'avoir peur des microbes
non là on a une consommation un peu trop
excessive justement de tout ce qui est
savon et c'est la théorie selon laquelle
on aurait plus d'allergies alimentaires
plus d'eczéma plus d'allergies car les
gens sont en cherche à être trop propre
camp ne veut plus qu'on touché le sol on
prend trop de douche c'est in a day
compris dans des situations on va dire
humaine je suis les la transpiration à
la base ça ne sent pas mauvais ça sent
mauvais au bout de quelques heures
lorsqu'on ne prend pas de douches ont
transpiré ce n'est pas sale ce n'est
normal après se dire que venir sur un
plateau télé débattre des odeurs
corporelles pour savoir si on va avoir
des rapports derrière ou pas c'est quand
même un peu des coudes la télévision est
ce que la personne tout à fait je cause
je connais votre compagne et non mais la
question c'est effectivement à partir
d'un certain degré d'intimité et ça fait
longtemps qu'on est en couple etc
est ce que vous êtes à cheval sur le
leader déjà d'une à la une hygiène
corporelle servirait au châble non mais
ça fait huit ans qu'on est ensemble donc
moi effectivement toutefois tout a bougé
de là mais non mais j'aime toutes ces
odeurs et voilà j'aime toutes ses
imperfections comme j'aime toutes ces
odeurs mais vous l'avez jamais tourné
vers l'avenir si vous êtes tout d'un
coup dans une situation où vous avez
envie l'une de l'autre et ces messieurs
elle revient du boulot et que peut-être
c'est un peu vous les départs va prendre
franchement est ce que vous vous le
faites avec votre compagnon alors
on est d'accord que quand vous êtes dans
le feu de l'action mais on s'en contre
car savoir c'est un peu la transpiration
la personne avec qui on évoquait ce
qu'on y va c'est agréable tue l'amour si
la personne tout d'un coup se lève alors
que vous êtes au boulot quoi au taf
ouais et qu'elle se lève pour aller
prendre une douche les temps vous vous
appelez ça être au taf web très bien à
quoi d'accord et on est concentré et la
personne se lève prendre sa douche c'est
fini tout redescend avancé non mais
c'est terminé et pilule en deviennent
faut arrêter on n'a pas fait pour ça il
a dit j'ai mis l'art elle l'a bien
compris ça non merci pas dire que c'est
quand on a envie on a envie hein quinze
minutes après d'accord avc elle vous dit
ah bah non deux secondes je dois d'abord
prendre une douche n'ont pas aussi
mature avec possible ah oui ce serait
anormal a alors mais vraiment vous êtes
des livres soit vous êtes hypocrite soir
une tuerie
non mais il ya un mois moi je tolère
odeur de la transpiration roi de la
longueur de la soeur ça j'avoue que
celle là elle est assez excitante mais
après tout les autres odeurs les pieds
les trucs mais c'est mort c'est à dire
je préfère qu'on nous coupe en plein
coït et qu'on aille prendre une douche
plutôt que de continuer sur sur un truc
ou fait fondre à montabon et où donc là
c'est vraiment un problème de désir qui
se bloquent direct est d'accord est ce
que c'est la saint maurice aujourd'hui
ce qu'on apprend qu'il a des poils afin
d'élire le truc connecte directement
vers ce que j'aimerais peut-être lé foot
à mary une conclusion de jimmy mohamed
qui adore ce genre de sujet peut aller
très bien écouté j'ai pris la parole une
fois un peu brodé pendant une demi-heure
comme ça il faut passer à autre chose
soit je tue l'émission
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]